happy Wednesday reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
bright burn trailer numero dos I was on
my way to the gym and then suddenly this
trailer came out and I was like oh snap
I should rush back oh I loved loved
loved the first trailer let's just go
right into it you know yeah we have a
patreon we always say that but you know
what I want to say today I've been
listening to this podcast called Conan
O'Brien needs a friend Conan O'Brien the
talk-show host to start up a podcast
this ain't a product placement or
anything like that at all
I just listened to it at night now like
an episode like once or twice a week and
it just makes me feel so good and it's a
great way to relax so you guys are
looking for a fun podcast to relax to
highly recommend Conan O'Brien needs a
friend or some videos on YouTube you
could access it on iTunes or the
podcasts on iPhone I know Y is very
talking about this I just wanted to
share something positive
that should hear a [ __ ] curse
husband difficulty
Oh
maybe Oh was she crazy - this woman why
is she suffering so much man yeah what
does she do she's the mother of that kid
[Applause]
ah special
[Music]
it's even in Kansas - yeah if it's a if
it's a spin on Superman I mean if people
were wondering that enough as it is I'd
hit it and I saw the news report bright
burn Kansas was like oh this is so
Superman this is a spin on no like he's
got to have some kind of Kryptonite that
right I would that has to be the the one
solution problem yeah you know as much
as like I injury stuff can be kind of a
cheap horror gimmick it still always
gets to me every single time yeah when
they go all the way and commit to it put
that in trailers a lobster I'm surprised
by how much they get away with the I the
self i gouging or something happening
with i in horror movie trailer like in
justin trailers they caught and they
constantly like throw that in there i
think is a little goes a very long way
horrifying
I mean III did get I felt like I got a
little bit of the sense of the gun humor
in the one moment where the guy was by
the truck and he was looking at the kid
from afar it was like no no
like reaction really awful I know can't
deal with that no no no no like this
Mario's like that because if it's like a
child and they're evil we do cuz at a
certain point you know you can't I don't
know there's such a barrier between you
and the rest of the world I was half
hoping that I mean this this still looks
like great to me and even though there's
this trailer especially no more trailers
please yeah I hope there's no more
trailers because I feel like they have
shown quite a lot of the movie and I was
already way sold the first time around
but I do kind of wish like as as
effective as that is and it makes sense
that he'd be bullied for being an
outsider and being kind of a we're in a
small town like a you know like that had
the idea of him being bullied you know
it isn't something that's far-fetched no
however I kind of wish that there's a
one part of it like I wish he just sort
of snap and became evil as opposed to oh
yeah he's bullied makes sense why he's
turning on everyone yeah yeah yeah
because that's another thing however
this is like a little nitpick on the
story like I feel like the rest of it's
still very very effective well you never
know maybe in the movie they'll hint
that ah there's something off about this
kid from the very beginning and all it's
gonna need is a little push or something
like that yeah and Elizabeth Banks I
feel like he's gonna be great in this
film I mean she she's always in both
trailers she's kind of just like here in
the beginning in the end you know but
it's very evident that out of besides
the kid she's the main character you
know like she's gonna be the Emily Blunt
of this yeah
when she's like I'm his real mother like
that moment right there she's gonna have
easily the most inner a conflict to deal
with on this side of the spectrum yeah
well I wonder ultimately what kind of
movie this is going to turn out to be
just because I feel like the premise is
very straight forward and this trailer
adds a little bit you know of new
footage and whatnot but it doesn't
really like recontextualize the story in
a major way so I feel like at the core
this is probably a very straightforward
thing so I wonder if there are any
surprises
showing us or anything like that because
I feel like yeah the the premise you
just kind of take it and go
note the surprises it's connected to
Garden to the galaxy there you go
this is the actual script for a
Guardians three that was going around
and then gun took it to Sony Pictures
said we're doing it here guys totally
mess up their whole thing with this one
but the effects look cool the shots in
here look great
there's a lot of style to be had here
but it even looks like that he starts
terrorizing his mom later on and the
because even they get that one final
Stan Rees zipping around and she's going
but it's it it's like I imagined it
maybe towards the end he's even become
maybe you started to see more of the
human side of this kid like the
emotional side of because I'm like why
the [ __ ] is he thrashed in that house so
maybe he's like conflicted on what to do
with his mom should he or should he not
kill her I'm hoping this movie goes
full-out even though I haven't
experienced the journey of the movie
yeah I'm kind of I'm half hoping that it
goes full out and kills Elizabeth Banks
just because movies wouldn't happen like
the dad will get killed but
knowledgeable banks but I'm hoping
Elizabeth Banks gets killed in this
movie you know that'd be nice there be a
nice turn of events yeah I mean that
could be a compelling central conflict
is the ultimate like maybe even mom just
can't get through to the boiler maybe
she succumbs to all the buddy else's
paranoia and he just is like nah
or maybe it's gonna have one of those
weird twists horror endings where she's
like yeah everyone in its got any one of
those two endings they're both terrible
ideas of mine but they they both it has
to be one of those - hell yeah before we
wrap this video up I would like to give
a page of the day shout-out to man named
Derek Mitchell Derek Mitchell is such a
cool guy and to shine about on bright
burn only makes the most sense you see
because Derek and I we
my girlfriend's not gonna be happy to
hear this I had an affair baby with a
Derek Mitchell and ever since then my
penis has been experiencing quite the
bright burn shoulda worn protection oh I
did but apparently whatever is inside of
Derek is so strong I went to the clinic
I got tested if they said I have
something because something's happening
down there and I don't know what never
seen anything like it before
that's why I told my girl like turned
the lights off last night we shut down
all the power in the building just so we
could do it it's just so she wouldn't
notice cuz Derek you've done something
to me man I'm morphing into something
that's like a frickin body horror movie
down here it's awful what did you give
me it's spreading without me even having
to do sexual things with other people
it's just spreading everywhere do not
sleep with Derek Mitchell no although it
was really good when we liked the actual
activity was really good I just the end
result the you know the guilt and also
the physical effects I've just not been
wasn't I haven't been able to sleep
since you guys are really loud yeah this
is only yesterday to refresh in my mind
anyway thanks Derek for being part of
our patreon page still it's the one way
you can make up to us subscribe to the
react nation click that notification
Bell
what do you think of bribe burn and
check us on patreon